[Musique]
israël palestine un confetti à l'échelle
de la planète les un confetti si lourd
par son histoire et ses conflits qu'ils
déstabilisent la marche du monde
combien de tentatives et autant d'échecs
pour faire vivre côte à côte ces deux
peuples
l'état juif créée par la communauté
internationale après l'horreur absolue
de la shoah et le peuple palestinien
installé depuis la nuit des temps sur
ses terres expulsé expropriés somine
aussi par la force comme s'ils devaient
payer pour des crimes commis par
d'autres
aujourd'hui israël ne cesse d'empiéter
sur la cisjordanie à grandir à coup de
force son espace au détriment des
palestiniens
l'ennemi numéro un de la paix c'est cela
ces colonies juives qui grignote le
territoire d'un futur état palestinien à
quelques kilomètres de jérusalem en
cisjordanie sur une terre aride et
décourageante se construisent encore et
toujours
plusieurs de ces implantations voici à
guy tôt fram pacifiste porte parole du
mouvement la paix maintenant
elle recense toutes ces constructions
illégales pour en informer l'opinion
internationale oui là c'est le coeur de
la cisjordanie
c'est jérusalem est les villages
palestiniens qui l'entourent hélas la
colonie de maale adoumim
elle a eu une deuxième colonie elle
s'appelle kedar et j'entends le bruit
des travaux
c'est en 1967 après la guerre des six
jours que commencent les implantations
juives
depuis cette date israël occupe la
cisjordanie ainsi que jérusalem est
la colonisation a débuté immédiatement
au début seuls quelques milliers de
volontaires sioniste participent
aujourd'hui c'est un système
tous ces points bleus autant de
constructions en marge du droit
international
autant d'obstacles à la paix en 2010 134
colonies 500000 israéliens qui vivent
[Musique]
mal et adoumim ressemble plus à une
ville nouvelle qu'à une colonie une
ville dortoir en fait une banlieue de
jérusalem qui abrite ceux qui n'ont pas
les moyens de se loger dans le centre
[Musique]
35000 personnes habitent ici
l'idéologie le sionisme c'est secondaire
ces israéliens sont venus pour vivre
mieux leur gouvernement leur a dit
qu'ils étaient chez eux alors ils le
sont allègrement un gel des
constructions des colonies a bien été
accordée pour six mois par le
gouvernement de benyamin nétanyahou une
parenthèse trop courte pour être
crédible
et lorsqu'à washington les pourparlers
commencent en septembre les travaux
redémarre dans les colonies aussi sec
oui ils sont tous palestiniens
bonjour je peux vous poser une question
c'est pour la télé française vous
construisez combien appartement ici je
crois qu'on en fait 12 ans bas et 15 ans
au ils construisent en tout six
bâtiments et dans chaque bâtiment il y
aura environ quatre appartements
est-ce qu'ils ont honte de travailler
oui ça ne fait pas plaisir du tout
travaillé ici est de construire ce qui
pourrait bien détruire leur propre futur
mais n'ont pas le choix il n'y a pas
d'autres travaillent donc ils
travaillent ici
l'autorité palestinienne refuse de
négocier tant que les travaux ne sont
pas suspendus dans les colonies pendant
ce temps les israéliens gagne du terrain
et ça dure depuis des années
le lotissement convoi lissiers comprend
trois mille cinq cents appartements et
tout ça a été construit dans les cinq
dernières années
ça veut dire que la construction ne
s'arrête jamais dans les colonies et
cela éloigne toujours plus les chances
de paix c'est une pub pour le nouveau
lotissement qu'elles construisent ici
ils ont mis ce joli petit bébé pour
attirer les gens c'est un endroit sûr et
agréable
oui pour montrer qu'ici on en sécurité
dans un cadre agréable pour élever ses
enfants
leur cible ce sont les jeunes couples
le promoteur du coin n'a pas d'états
d'âme et il n'aime pas les caméras
bonjour c'est une équipe de télé
française il s'intéresse à la
construction ils veulent savoir combien
d'imac vous construisez et combien ça
coûte
il faut un film sur ce que vous faites
ici et s'il ya une possibilité d'arriver
à un accord gouvernemental
non y'a aucune chance je croyais oui et
c'est pour ça qu'on est là pour faire en
sorte que ça n'arrive pas bon et il dit
que ça suffit qu'il a du travail et
qu'il ne veut pas faire partie d'un
reportage
merci au revoir
[Musique]
quand vous voyez ça vous êtes en colère
je suis en colère c'est seulement quand
je regarde l'ensemble
si je devais m'énerver tous les jours je
serai quelqu'un de très en colère haro
sur les colons c'est un peu facile
ce sont bien les différents
gouvernements israéliens ils les ont
encouragés à s'installer
nous sommes allés à hébron au sud de la
cisjordanie
à 40 kilomètres à peine de jérusalem
[Musique]
cette ville palestinienne qui abrite le
caveau des patriarches un lieu saint
pour les musulmans mais aussi pour les
juifs
ici c'est plutôt la haine que l'amour
abraham pour les juifs ibrahim pour les
musulmans auraient été inhumé ici elle
c'est chantal et lui rony akrich un
couple de colons israéliens d'origine
française
ils vont à hébron comme d'autres
ailleurs à sainte chapelle de temps en
temps leurs racines leur religion le
fait d'habiter gijon c'est d'habiter ce
lieu
j'avais pas dire mythique mais c'est ce
lieu emblématique c'est à dire qu'il est
russell tellement d'histoires que vous
vous sentez attaché rattachés aux
sources de cette histoire la fois de
rosny et chantal les a motivés pour
s'installer dès 1987 dans la colonie de
kiryat arba tout près d'hébron ce n'est
ni la plus sûre ni la plus modérée leurs
croyances pour le coup a balayé toutes
les craintes
aujourd'hui 8000 colons vivent ici sous
protection armée permanente
lorsqu'ils ont quitté la région
parisienne
ils sont arrivés au début de l'intifada
ils ont eu droit à l'épreuve des pierres
il était pratiquement baptisé par les
pierres pratiquement tous les jours
pratiquement tous les jours les bus
n'était pas protégée dont klépierre
rentrer à l'intérieur on nous a tiré
dessus aussi on a tiré sur le bus
heureusement j'ai pas été blessé avant
j'étais très choquée ce jour là et j'ai
même perdu un bébé à cause de ça dans la
peur parce que j'étais enceinte
voilà le mari de chantal ronnie est
professeur d'études religieuses et
infirmiers réanimateur nous ne sommes
pas là par hasard
nous pensons réaliser ce pourquoi le
peuple juif durant deux mille ans a
tellement était comment je dirais mené
entre les sociétés d'accueil de recueil
le plus souvent dans les sociétés de
cercueils
mais il a aspiré envers et contre tous
les aléas de ces histoires là à se
retourner et à cette vie qu'il aurait
voulu de plénitude de tranquillité de
sérénité
chantal travail au supermarché de kiryat
arba
en france elle était expert comptable
ici elle a mis les mains dans la farine
bah là ça doit vous rappeler la france
alors tout à fait j'ai retrouvé les
croissants au beurre et les baguettes
moi je sais que c'est chez moi et depuis
longtemps je veux dire c'est pas deux il
ya quelques années j'ai toujours appris
que qu'israël nous avait été donné au
peuple juif par dieu avec les
palestiniens ils sont récemment ils ont
moins de légitimité
ici je crois mais peu lui n'est pas
vivre ici je veux dire mais je les
renvoie pas où je leur dis pas d'aller
habiter ailleurs mais si si ils ne
veulent pas que moi j'habite ici il ya
d'autres pays peuvent habiter ailleurs
si moi je les gènes et peuvent aller
ailleurs et les palestiniens réplique
ailleurs c'est ici éternel débat pour la
majorité des colons de kiryat arba
partir dit si jamais vous seriez prêt à
partir en échange de la paix je
n'écouterai même pas je ne le ferai pas
en plus je pense que ça n'arrivera pas
et qu'on ne nous le demandera pas
de toute façon benyamin nétanyahou a
déclaré que est bon et le caveau des
patriarches plus particulièrement sont
un héritage juif et nous devons le
garder
pourquoi voudriez vous qu'on nous
expulse de kiryat arba
selon les plans de paix envisagée si un
état palestinien était créé un jour
certaines colonies devraient être
évacués que ferait alors ronnie et
chantal nous prendrons nos armes et nos
bagages et nous rentrerons à la maison
car la vox populi la vox populi est
d'abord et avant tout la voie que nous
entendons c'est à dire la voie
démocratique d'israël mais sachez que
jusqu'à maintenant une grosse majorité
d'israël est très attaché à révolte très
attaché à ce que révèle représente
vous passerez pas pour rester ici
se battre contre qui contre mon peuple
gouvernement certes sans pleurer un sens
c'est comme ça complètement
[Musique]
le lendemain je suis passé côté
palestinien sous l'oeil d'arafat
ils veillent encore
à ramallah siège de l'autorité
palestinienne j'ai retrouvé une vieille
connaissance
une figure de la résistance
palestinienne c'était à beyrouth en 1973
lorsque des milliers de palestiniens
avaient trouvé refuge au liban
lui qui a mené les combats les plus
radicaux oeuvre aujourd'hui pour la paix
yasser abed rabbo et membre de
l'autorité palestinienne
l'embryon d'état reconnu par la
communauté internationale et israël en
vous serez vous m'avez aidé à l'époque
aller à rachaya elles font rares au sud
du liban avec vos milices la branche
faisant oui oui vous avez fait ça et
pourquoi cette immense tableau de
guernica dans votre bureau
j'aime ce tableau c'est un beau symbole
de la façon dont un peuple peut renaître
de ses cendres et que la vie malgré tout
la souffrance c'est l'agonie sur les
visages de tout le monde y compris du
cheval que la vie gagne toujours à la
fin et qu'elle est plus forte que tout
je crois en la vie la colonisation
devait s'arrêter
elle continue le problème demain si vous
arrivez à vous entendre politiquement
c'est de savoir comment construire un
état palestinien avec toutes ses
colonies
fb c'est la question que je me pose
chaque jour chaque matin aux éclats avec
ce qui se passe sur le terrain
les isles
les israéliens sont fous les j'insiste
sur ce mot
ils sont fous a glissé dans le même
temps ils demandent la reconnaissance
d'un état juif
joost et tout bio éco et accueillez et
sur le terrain ils créent eux mêmes un
état de fait again contre notre volonté
contre celle de la communauté
internationale à gaz et même contre leur
intention déclarée en chine
que peuvent-ils bien donc avoir en tête
tout d'abord nous n'allons pas nous
évaporé la catastrophe
le grand exil de 1948 ne se reproduira
pas des centaines de milliers de
palestiniens expulsés de chez eux vers
nulle part
un des go to nowhere
cela n'arrivera jamais plus nous sommes
ici ceci est notre terre notre patrie
c'est la terre de nos pères de nos
ancêtres nous n'avons pas d'autre
endroit où aller
pendant des années j'ai couvert comme on
dit dans le métier ce conflit j'ai
autant la tâche d'un côté que de l'autre
mais je le constate les partisans de la
paix semble progresser plus vite côté
palestinien qu'israélien ilan
greilsammer fait aujourd'hui figure
d'exception professeur de sciences
politiques à l'université bar ilan de
jérusalem ce français d'origine immigrée
en israël il ya 40 ans et bien que
sioniste convaincu il défend le droit
des palestiniens à avoir un état
si vous avez envie de la paix si vous
avez envie de deux états pourquoi le
gouvernement israélien ne prend pas les
décisions concernant les colonisations
et ne stoppe pas les constructions
puisqu'elles ont repris là alors je
dirais que il n'ya deux raisons
principales la première c'est que il
n'ya pas d'opposition véritablement
forte en israël à la poursuite de la
colonisation
les groupes qu'on désigne comme la paix
maintenant comme le plan de la paix
quand la gauche sioniste
oui sont très faibles dans la réalité
politique israélienne et l'ensemble de
la population finalement ne voit pas de
mal à ce que le gouvernement continue à
construire dans une certaine mesure dans
les territoires ça c'est la première
raison est la deuxième je dirais c'est
qu'il n'y a pas de pression extérieure
sur israël ni du président obama a mis
du président sarkozy ni de qui que ce
soit pour arrêter cette colonisation
[Musique]
jérusalem jérusalem ville trois fois
sainte pour les juifs les chrétiens et
les musulmans
jerusalem tant de fois disputés et tant
de fois conquise
jerusalem que visite des millions de
pèlerins des trois religions
chaque année
[Musique]
jerusalem terrain d'une autre bataille
entre israéliens et palestiniens qui se
disputent la ville comme capitale
jérusalem c'est l'autre noeud du conflit
pendant mon séjour
le gouvernement a annoncé la
construction de 1300 nouveaux logements
à jérusalem est la partie arabe de la
ville
ici aussi la présence juive s'étend
chaque jour dans le quartier de cheikh
jarrah
ce sont quatre familles palestiniennes
qui ont été expulsées de leurs maisons
depuis des colons israéliens s'y sont
installés
l'année dernière la famille hanoune a
été expulsé de sa maison par décision de
justice
ils reviennent presque tous les jours
avoir l'office des nations unies pour
les réfugiés les a installés sur ses
terres en 1948 au moment de la création
d'israël
elle était alors jordanienne il leur a
construit des maisons
les colons israéliens conteste
aujourd'hui il en soit propriétaire et
les tribunaux les ont suivis charial la
fille de la famille se souvient du jour
de l'expulsion un traumatisme
c'était l'été dernier il était 5 heures
du matin ils ont débarqué et ils nous
ont jetés à la rue on n'a même pas eu le
temps de prendre nos affaires
le quartier était bouclée des deux côtés
il y avait plus de 500 policiers
on s'est retrouvé dans la rue j'ai vu
toute ma famille là en pyjama et pieds
nus
aujourd'hui les annuler n'ont pas
retrouvé de domicile qui sont hébergés
par des membres de leur famille mais
impossible pour raul à la mer d'oublier
sa vie d'avant à chaque fois je me
demande de quel droit ils se trouvent
dans la maison la maison j'ai tous mes
souvenirs ceux de mon mari de mes
enfants
de quel droit ça me détruit chaque jour
ça me tue à petit feu
en revenant dans leur quartier
il croise souvent des colons israéliens
voleur va au diable vous est pourri
alors vous êtes content de vivre dans
une maison gratuitement
ils ont volé nos maisons mais nous
reviendrons pas la grâce de dieu tout le
monde et de leur côté la police et le
gouvernement
c'est normal qui nous nargue
on n'a pas le droit de s'installer
devant notre maison
alors tous les jours on vient ici on
prend des chaises et on s'installe sous
l'arbre on observe les colons qui
profitent de la maison de nos voisins et
qui prennent notre place c'est tout ce
qu'on peut faire
la confrontation pacifique va durer des
heures dans le quartier
une trentaine de familles arabes sont
ainsi menacés d'expulsion là encore
c'est le droit du sol qui va mettre le
feu aux poudres ce qui leur est arrivé
nous a beaucoup affectés
j'ai peur qu'il nous arrive la même
chose
c'est pour ça qu'on les soutient et moi
même je suis en sursis puisque le
tribunal m'a permis de rester ici que
jusqu'en mai 2011
je parle pas anglais
je parle pas à la télé difficile pour
vous de vivre ici difficile non mais
c'est pas étrange d'avoir sa personne
assise en face de chez vous et qui vous
disent que vous ne devriez pas être là
non on est plein de juifs ici donc vous
pensez vous avez le droit d'être ici
bien sûr
et pourquoi c'est notre pays
no coment mais la famille hanoune ne
perd pas espoir
elle a fait appel auprès des tribunaux
si les tribunaux israéliens s'estime
compétent sur la partie arabe de
jérusalem
c'est parce que l'état hébreu occupe
cette partie de la ville ici en vert
depuis 1967
en 1981 il a purement et simplement un
excès déclarant jérusalem capitale
éternelle et indivisible d'israël et du
peuple juif
la communauté internationale a condamné
cette annexion mais israël passe outre
depuis près de deux cent mille colons se
sont installés à jérusalem est y compris
au coeur même de la vieille ville
du point de vue des israéliens je pense
que c'est comme si on se trouvait en
israël même
oui et donc si des familles d'une autre
communauté veulent s'installer sur les
juifs d'un carter ham
ils le font en fait c'est un geste
politique
c'est un geste politique oui il y a
toujours eu depuis 1967
des familles et des courants religieux
voulait s'installer dans tout ça
jérusalem sur les gouvernements
israéliens qui ont autorisé cette
installation donc ça correspond jusqu'à
aujourd'hui jusqu'au gouvernement de
tenir ou à une politique
détermine la politique du gouvernement
netanyahu
une coalition de partis de droite
d'extrême droite et d'ultra orthodoxes
fait le jeu des organisations juives les
plus radicales surtout à jérusalem
daniel luria et le porte-parole
d'intérêt de co anime une organisation
sioniste religieuse qui milite pour la
judaïsation de jérusalem est
son discours a le mérite d'être clair je
me demande toujours pourquoi entre 1948
et 1967
s'il avait un désir aussi fort de créer
cet état palestinien pour ce soi-disant
peuple palestinien pourquoi rien n'a été
fait en fait c'est parce que la nation
palestinienne n'a jamais existé elle
n'existe pas l'organisation de daniel
luria est surtout actif dans la vieille
ville de jérusalem sa victoire ce sont
ces drapeaux israéliens qui flotte sur
certaines maisons du quartier haram plus
de mille colons israéliens vivent
aujourd'hui dans des maisons achetées
par intérêt qu anime dans cette partie
de la ville l'organisation est financée
par des dons de particuliers
60% d'entre eux proviennent de la
diaspora juive américaine
ça c'est une acquisition très importante
pour nous cette maison s'appelle la
maison de valero c'est un très beau
bâtiment les trois quarts de la maison
sont maintenant aux mains des juifs
c'est un bonjour ça va
en pleine installation les futurs
occupants
les étudiants d'une école religieuse et
dans la cour de dos le dernier occupant
palestiniens de la maison une cour
séparé en deux par une barrière en fer
un fétu de paille en fait que le souffle
de la colonisation finira par emporter
pourquoi tu film pourquoi tu filmes je
vais pas demander à ce qu'il filme c'est
bon c'est bon désolé le propriétaire
palestinien a lui aussi tendu ces
drapeaux devant son appartement du
premier étage film ces drapeaux c'est ce
qui les dérange
il est écrit qu'il n'y a de dieu
qu'allah et mahomet est son prophète et
ça dérange le gouvernement israélien
regarde combien ils ont mis le drapeau
de leur côté 1 2 3 moi ça me dérange pas
de quel drapeau tu parles celui là où
celui du hamas mais c'est pas le hamas
et ça c'est quoi c'est un drapeau qui
dit qu'il n'y a de dieu qu'allah mais
celui qui à côté
ce drapeau c'est celui de l'autorité
palestinienne vous avez fait la paix
avec eux ah bon il ya la paix et où ça
chez vous dans les territoires que vous
occupez c'est une simple transaction
commerciale
quelqu'un veut vendre quelqu'un veut
acheter et les juifs s'installent ici au
coeur de jérusalem
là où bat le pouls du monde juif il y a
cinq mois j'ai reçu un appel d'intérêt
de co anime
ils n'ont proposé 3 millions de dollars
pour ma maison et si je vends juif je
trahis mon peuple
silwan un quartier de jérusalem est où
500 colons juifs vivent au milieu de 60
mille palestiniens
un quartier où depuis plusieurs mois les
heurts sont fréquents
[Musique]
des images qui rappellent celles de
l'intifada dans ce quartier
israël détruit des maisons
palestiniennes daniel luria et son
organisation comme un pied de nez
construit cet immeuble qui abrite une
famille de colons
[Applaudissements]
là vous pouvez voir les traces de
nombreuses attaques sur l'immeuble et
des cocktails molotov il y en a 3 de ce
côté ci c'est qui daniel duriez intérêts
de quoi nîmes
vous avez une pièce d'identité portes
blindées gardes de sécurité privés
[Musique]
tu peux pas filmer ce que daniel luria
ne veut pas que nous filmions ce sont
ces gardes frontière en uniforme vert
des forces de sécurité régulières de
l'état d'israël qui protège les colons
ce qu'il tient en revanche à nous
montrer
c'est une aire de jeux pour les enfants
des collants sur le toit de l'immeuble
c'est pas vrai partout dans le monde
la même propagande les enfants devant
c'est une provocation
la simple présence d'un juif conduit à
ce genre de réaction des cocktails
molotov des tonnes de pierres lancées
depuis les environs et ça c'est pas
vraiment un signe de bienvenue
tu reçois ça dans la tête tu es mort
comme à hébron toujours cette référence
à la religion
on est dans les faubourgs du mont du
temple
là vous avez la cité de david c'est ici
que tout s'est passé pour des
générations de juifs qui ont prié en dix
ans l'année prochaine à jérusalem
c'est de ça qu'il parle les juifs ont
plus que le droit de vivre ici de
rentrer à la maison
d'habitude les habitants de l'immeuble
préfère ne pas parler à la presse
bonjour la présence de daniel luria
rassurent cette mère de famille qui
habite ici depuis deux ans et demi
le vrai problème vous savez c'est qu'on
est à jérusalem ici et pas ailleurs dans
le monde
c'est notre terre ici et les arabes
n'ont pas encore pris conscience en fait
ils pensent qu'ils peuvent faire ce
qu'ils veulent
face à cette politique de colonisation
des dizaines d'opposants manifestent
tous les vendredis depuis environ un an
[Musique]
ce jour là les manifestants droit à une
visite de soutien de jimmy carter
l'ex-président américain
il est membre du groupe des sages formé
de personnalités qui tente de promouvoir
la paix dans le monde
que pensez-vous des colonies je suis
contre elles sont illégales et sont un
obstacle à la paix il a du boulot du
mieux
[Musique]
la manifestation se déroule devant le
quartier de cheikh jarrah bouclé par la
police israélienne pour l'occasion
côte à côte des palestiniens et des
israéliens est en première ligne
notre famille hanoune expulsé de sa
maison l'année dernière
notre problème n'est pas un problème
religieux entre musulmans chrétiens et
juifs
les israéliens qui sont ici aujourd'hui
pour nous soutenir prouver au monde
entier que le problème est politique
le problème est avec israël pas avec les
juifs et la manif se termine devant la
maison d hanoune
[Musique]
dans la jungle il peut y avoir une
clairière et dans le désert l'oasis
à jérusalem c'est ici que souffle
l'esprit de la paix de la fraternité de
l'intelligence juste une école avec le
plus ambitieux des programmes l'école
s'appelle main dans la main elle n'est
ni juive ni musulmane ni chrétienne ni
israélienne ni palestinienne elle est
tout simplement une pépite d'espérance
deux israéliens l'ont créée
il a 13 ans il existe seulement quatre
établissements de ce type en israël ici
travail et sa muse 500 élèves de la
maternelle au lycée
ils ne se connaissent pas à la récré
nous on est palestiniens pourquoi vous
avez choisi cette école
et musulmans et les juifs sont réunis
parce que je suis convaincu qu'il est
capital que les enfants comprennent
qu'ils doivent vivre ensemble et qu'on
dépasse l'archaïsme des civilisations
des cultures et des politiques il ya
beaucoup de choses qui nous sépare des
israéliens notamment ce qui concerne la
politique mais il faut se rendre à
l'évidence nous vivons ensemble sur la
même terre pourquoi vous avez choisi de
mettre les enfants dans cette école
mon mari est arabe moi je suis juive
donc c'est la seule école possible pour
ma fille à jérusalem dans une école
classique ce serait très difficile pour
elle dans une école arabe elle serait
considérée comme une suivez-le dans une
école juive
on l'a très très commune arabe et moi je
ne veux pas de ça pour les profs
viennent aussi de communautés
différentes
le proviseur et palestiniens mais peu
importe son origine
seule compte sa compétence et cette
partie de la ville et arabes
oui c'est un quartier arabe et de ce
côté ci ça s'appelle pattes
c'est un quartier juif nous sommes à la
frontière entre les deux donc on est une
passerelle entre les deux côtés
formidable passerelle cette école est ce
que l'on entend dans les classes permet
de croire encore de croire toujours à un
avenir pacifié voici un petit groupe
d'étudiants qui ne parlent pas arabe
auquel nous apprenons la langue et là je
vous présente ronit bien qu'elle soit
juive elle enseigne l'arabe c'est une
question de principe
les arabes sont obligés d'apprendre
l'hébreu
ils doivent apprendre l'hébreu
sinon ils n'ont aucune chance de réussir
dans ce pays et on pense qu'en apprenant
l'arabe
on pourra communiquer avec des arabes
dans la rue devenir amis et aussi créer
une sorte d'égalité sans l'arabe il n'y
a pas de ville
moi j'adore la langue arabe c'est vrai
que ça peut paraître bizarre mais
j'adore l'arabe
pour moi c'est la plus belle langue du
monde bien plus belle que l'hébreu en
tout cas je le pense et je suis juive
merci de préciser
[Musique]
pour l'instant c'est une petite goutte
d'eau encore dans le système il sera il
serait bien et palestiniens si ça
progresse est ce que vous n'avez pas
peur que ceux qui ne sont pas favorables
à la paix finissent par vous attaquez
oui dans cible non la peur ne fait pas
partie de notre programme
au contraire il y à des tensions ou
dehors mais notre pédagogie fait que nos
élèves se sentent bien en sécurité ici
et nous avons mises en place pour eux
des programmes pour qu'ils ne se
laissent pas influencer par les tensions
à l'extérieur au contraire notre but est
d'en faire des ambassadeurs dans leur
communauté pour convaincre leur
entourage qu'il ya une autre voie
nous essayons d'allumer une chandelle et
je crois que nous sommes une chandelle
dans l'obscurité que vous voyez ici
c'est une grosse chandelle
oui merci beaucoup
[Musique]
vivre en bonne intelligence entre
israéliens et palestiniens
il arrivera at on un jour
la lumière est magnifique dans cette
école à quelques mètres c'est l'immense
mur de béton et son obscurité
israël a construit pour se protéger des
terroristes palestiniens
c'est un succès et pourtant c'est aussi
l'aveu d'un formidable échec
c'est un rideau infranchissable qui
isole et interdit le dialogue
il empêche aussi bien sur les attentats
de 2000 à 2005
des kamikazes ont fait des centaines de
victimes civiles ces extrémistes
palestiniens ont alors donné raison à
l'état hébreu à sa paranoïa à son
exigence sécuritaire
[Musique]
le mur de séparation qui par endroit est
un grillage mesure aujourd'hui plus de
400 km de long les passera au final les
problème le mur ne suis pas les limites
de l'actuel état d'israël
il englobe aussi près de 10 % de la
cisjordanie afin d'y inclure certaines
colonies
un obstacle de plus au processus de paix
il y à ce mur il ya une séparation entre
jérusalem est et le reste de la
cisjordanie
chaque journée chaque ville a sa propre
prison à ciel ouvert
ce qu'on observe aujourd'hui c'est la
mise en place d'un système d'apartheid
avant on était dans une logique
d'occupation maintenant elle a évolué en
aparté et pourtant malgré le mur les
blocus l'occupation des colonies je sens
comme un frémissement côté palestinien
une vie qui se normalise ici ou là une
économie qui décolle depuis 2008 le taux
de croissance est devenue % par an
l'autorité palestinienne tente depuis
peu souvent avec succès d'assainir ses
finances de faire le ménage parmi les
fonctionnaires corrompus
du coup l'aide de la communauté
internationale est revenu et l'argent de
la diaspora palestinienne aussi bien sur
le pays vit sous perfusion
l'aide étrangère permet de bâtir alors
que la cisjordanie ne produit que très
peu de richesse ramallah à capitale
provisoire à 14 kilomètres seulement de
jérusalem est devenue une ville
dynamique et attractive plein de
chantier et de cafés branchés
voici bachar al masri un pionnier de
cette nouvelle palestine il a fait
fortune à l'étranger
aujourd'hui il revient pour investir
massivement en cisjordanie il ya une
sorte de moore économique
pourquoi qu'est ce qui s'est passé les
choses s'améliorent c'est sûr en tout
cas on dirait qu'elle s'améliore ces
deux dernières années l'autorité
palestinienne a réussi à garantir un
niveau de sécurité sans précédent
je parle de la sécurité intérieure
palestinian cela a permis à beaucoup de
gens de faire un nouveau des projets de
sortir et c'est ce que vous observez
aujourd'hui que les gens ont pris
confiance et n'ont plus peur d'investir
ils n'ont pas le choix ils veulent vivre
ce n'est pas parce qu'ils ont confiance
en l'économie ou en investissement
c'est parce qu'ils ont envie de vivre et
de rattraper un retard sur la vie c'est
pour cela que j'appelle ça un petit boum
même s'il est important ce n'est rien à
côté de ce que ce boom sera si la
situation politique s'améliore
à une dizaine de kilomètres à peine au
nord de ramallah un chantier de plus est
incroyable celui ci est palestinien al
masri a fait le pari une aventure un peu
folle de construire une ville nouvelle
palestinienne
les travaux comment s'appellent les
attentes sont énormes
le symbole est immense bachar al masri
m'a invité sur ce chantier unique
c'est la première fois depuis la
création d'israël que nos villes
palestiniennes voit le jour voilà la
première phase qu'on appellera à bien
c'est sur une superficie de 850 mhz est
étonnant et on va faire la première
construction de six ans
c'est à dire si quartier 1 2 3 4 5 6 et
ce qu'on voit ici
les premières constructions et
excavations pour les six quartiers sur
les collines millénaire de la palestine
une nouvelle vision huillard devient
réalité
[Musique]
la première ville nouvelle palestinienne
va moderniser le paysage de la palestine
rawabi la colline en français un projet
de 345 millions d'euros approuvée par
l'autorité palestinienne est financé en
partie par des investisseurs du qatar 48
l'habitant de toutes les classes
sociales devraient y vivre les
appartements sont déjà en vente
les pubs ressemble étrangement à celle
vue dans la colonie israélienne de maalé
adoumim rawabi répond besoin de la
palestine d'aujourd'hui en posant les
fondations de la palestine de demain
[Musique]
pourquoi vous avez décidé de construire
cette ville pourquoi pas c'est une bonne
question
c'est essentiellement parce que nous
avons réalisé qu'il ya une forte demande
de logements
il n'y a qu'à regarder parmi nos
employés ils ont des emplois stables
un revenu correct et pourtant 92%
d'entre eux ne possèdent pas de maison
et il n'en possède pas parce que les
logements sont chers à cause des
limitations imposées à l'extension des
villes est parce qu avec l'occupation
les palestiniens n'ont pas eu le droit
de construire en dehors des piles
les travaux sont ralentis le
morcellement par israël de la
cisjordanie en trois zones avec des
niveaux de sécurité de circulation
différents complique tout
rawabi est situé dans la zone contrôlée
par l'autorité palestinienne mais ces
accès traverse sur 3 km le périmètre
israélien qui protège juste en face la
colonie dattakhel une zone interdite aux
palestiniens
et à tahar est on construit aussi c'est
comme une course de vitesse
impitoyable pour savoir qui plantera le
premier son drapeau je peux vous assurer
que eux ils construiront sans avoir à
faire des études d'impact sur
l'environnement sans avoir à se soucier
de l'accès par la route de l'accès à
l'eau ou aux matériaux ni à ce souci du
permis de construire ou à quoi que ce
soit d'autre
ils ont tout ce qu'ils veulent ils ne
sont pas plus de deux cents à vivre là
il y a des centaines de soldats qui les
protègent
pendant que nous nous sommes ici à
attendre attendre depuis plus de trois
ans pour avoir une simple route d'accès
bachar al masri et ses partenaires
prennent un gros risque financier avec
ce projet mais il attend de cet
investissement beaucoup plus qu'un
simple profit c'est l'optimisme qui nous
permet d'avancer mais nous sommes avant
tout réaliste nous faisons ce projet en
tenant compte de la situation politique
actuelle et non en fonction d'une
évolution future
si le futur est meilleur alors nous
serons septième ciel mais ce ne sera
peut-être pas le cas
et dans ce cas nous pourrions avoir de
graves problèmes le problème des
palestiniens
c'est d'abord leurs divisions politiques
[Musique]
yasser arafat grands leaders avaient
réussi à unifier la résistance mais il
n'a pas su gérer le pouvoir laissant
progresser le terrorisme la corruption
dans les territoires
[Musique]
après sa mort en 2004 c'est toujours le
fatah qui règne sous l'égide de son
successeur mahmoud abbas
[Musique]
mais en 2006 gaza fait bande à part le
hamas un parti religieux qui appelle à
la destruction d'israël remporte les
élections législatives et l'année
suivante il prend le contrôle de la
bande de gaza lors d'affrontements
fratricides et qui dans des dizaines de
fonctionnaires de l'autorité
palestinienne
le rêve d'unité de yasser arafat silwan
ya un peu plus et en palestine comme en
israël
l'espoir d'un dialogue s'estompe je
dirais que la droite israélienne peut
jouer du fait qu'il n'y a pas un
gouvernement palestinien avec qui
traiter
il y a l'autorité palestinienne mais
vous savez que le hamas a dit que tout
accord que signerait l'autorité
palestinienne avec israël est nulle et
non avenue
il traite mahmoud abbas de traîtres à la
cause palestinienne le hamas contrôlent
toujours la bande de gaza ce territoire
de 40 km de long
coincé entre israël et l'egypte
sur cette enclave s'entassent plus d'un
million et demi de palestiniens soumis
depuis 2007 à un blocus israélien imposé
après la prise du pouvoir par le hamas
le mouvement qui refuse pour l'instant
de reconnaître israël ne participe pas
aux négociations de paix la fracture
entre la masse fatah on la retrouve au
sein même des familles palestiniennes
ici par exemple chez nasrallah la fais
le père a voté ramasse et fadi son fils
aîné fatah
et tu peux me dire comment le fatah vie
en cisjordanie
comment ils vivent si ce n'est pas grâce
à israël
si israël n'occupait pas la cisjordanie
le fatah auraient disparu même le hamas
les a battus en cisjordanie c'est la
vérité c'est ça la vérité moi je pense
que le hamas est soutenu par l'iran qui
le finance pour faire de gaza une base
iranienne et alors il est où le problème
si l'iran finance le hamas c'est un état
musulman qui soutient un mouvement
d'indépendance qui combat l'occupation
aujourd'hui la fais le partisan du hamas
est un peu désappointé
mais il ne regrette pas son choix la
situation s'est aggravée
le blocus a été instaurée par ce que le
hamas a été élu
la pression s'est accentuée sur la
population
les israéliens veulent qu'on incrimine
le hamas
que ce soit à cause de lui que nous
n'ayons rien à manger rien à boire et
pas de travail mais ce n'est pas vrai
c'est l'occupation qui est la vraie
responsable je sais qu'ils les
sympathisants du hamas et qu'il aime ce
mouvement mais demande lui qu'est ce que
le hamas a fait pour lui en ce moment
une api de travail pour fadi sans un
accord entre fatah et hamas
l'avenir est compromis tout ça c'est à
cause de la division 1 pouvoir diviser
ne peut pas négocier il faut d'abord
régler le problème de cette division
c'est ce qui affaiblit le peuple
palestinien est ce que vous pensez
parvenir à un accord avec le hamas
franchement je ne sais pas quand nous
arriverons à un accord avec le hamas
ils essayent d'obtenir de notre part une
concession majeure que nous
reconnaissions leur contrôle sur gaza
gaza et qu'on le prenne comme un fait
accompli et defacto d'une certaine
manière cela ressemble à ce que nous
font subir les israéliens nous ne
l'accepterons jamais élections les
élections sont la seule façon d'accéder
au pouvoir
tous propos il n'y en a pas d'autre noko
d'état pas de coup d'état ne met pas de
régime militaire
pas de règne au nom de la religion
n'accepte pas cela alors il n'y aura pas
de réconciliation
[Musique]
en attendant d'hypothétiques élections
dans les territoires gaza survit au jour
le jour avec le blocus israélien le
chômage dépasse les 40 % et 70 % de la
population vit sous le seuil de pauvreté
la fais le père de famille est au
chômage avant le blocus qui travaillait
comme maçon en israël aujourd'hui pour
gagner sa vie il fait de petits
chantiers
cet après midi là d'un voisin le système
des rois ça c'est du vieux béton il est
très vieux en le cassant tout petit
pierre après on le mélange au ciment on
le recycle on en fabrique un nouveau car
on en a pas les juifs nous interdisent
d'en apporter à gaza la fesse gagnant
une semaine de travail
ce qu'ils gagnent et temps d'une journée
en israël et ironie de l'histoire les
gravats qui l'utilisent proviennent des
maisons détruites par les bombardements
israéliens
fadi son fils était fonctionnaire pour
l'autorité palestinienne depuis
l'arrivée du hamas au pouvoir il n'a
plus le droit de travailler
mais il perçoit toujours son salaire un
peu moins de 500 euros mensuels
tout juste de quoi faire vivre sa
famille de huit enfants pour lui israël
ne souhaite pas la création d'un état
palestinien
le blocus a un but bien précis il sera
elle à bloquer l'économie en imposant un
blocus sur gaza comme ça les
palestiniens qui sont victimes de ce
blocus cesse d'avoir des revendications
sur jérusalem sur le droit au retour des
réfugiés sur la cisjordanie
notre obsession c'est comment lever le
blocus de gaza et on a tout oublié le
blocus est devenu notre obsession
voilà la réalité est bien sûr ça sert
les intérêts d'israël
[Musique]
la famille nasrallah vie dans cette
maison restaurée après un bombardement
israélien
parmi la vingtaine de personnes qui
l'habitent il ya omar et amena les
frères cadets de fady comme beaucoup de
jeunes gazaouis ils s'imaginent tailleur
internet et leur fenêtre sur le monde
le rêve partir à l'étranger comme leurs
copains dont ils regardent sans cesse
les photos comme celle du cousin qui vit
aujourd'hui en nouvelle zélande
il vivait à gaza pas loin de chez nous
il est parti là bas il s'est marié et a
fondé une famille et vous l'envié
ah oui et pourquoi pas ce qu'il a réussi
à partir d'ici et a quitté cette misère
[Musique]
les jeunes gazaouis aurait t'il baisser
les bras ne croirai clip plus en un
futur état palestinien
on s'est rencontré et a très longtemps
dans une entrevue qu'est ce qui a été
positif depuis cette époque pour le
peuple palestinien
oui nous avons acquis une reconnaissance
internationale sans précédent que c'est
d'un tête sur le fait que nous avons le
droit en tant que peuple d'avoir notre
indépendance
l'occupation israélienne doit cesser et
que la seule solution est la solution à
deux états tous tes se douche à l'époque
c'était un rêve pour nous aujourd'hui
c'est devenu une réalité politique
mais cette réalité s'évanouit chaque
jour un peu plus sur le terrain c'est
une contradiction
nous voulons que la communauté
internationale fasse quelque chose et
surtout qu'elle prenne des mesures et
pas seulement qu'elle fasse des
déclarations sur la solution à deux
états oui on en a marre des déclarations
de solidarité aux soldats
aujourd'hui je crois que beaucoup de
gens non seulement ici au moyen-orient
mais dans le monde se disent c'est un
problème qui n'a pas de solution jamais
les israéliens et palestiniens se
mettront d'accord je ne suis pas de ceux
là je pense qu'il faut être beaucoup
plus actifs on est actif ça veut dire
que le plan de la paix en israël
reprennent du poil de la bête ça veut
dire que les palestiniens modérés
disent très clairement les choses au
niveau de la reconnaissance de l'état
d'israël comme état juif et je pense que
le monde entier y compris les européens
et les américains ne doivent pas perdre
de vue que ce problème est fondamental
il est fondamental parce qu'il est lié à
d'autres choses comme le terrorisme
international comme la montée des forces
fondamentalistes dans le monde arabe
tout cela est dangereux et tout cela
irait mieux si le conflit israélo
palestinien était en voie d'être résolu
un état palestinien
c'est une nécessité une évidence pour
tous ceux qui dans le monde souhaitent
la stabilité et la paix voici tel aviv à
60 km de jérusalem
et c'est pourtant un tout autre monde
sur le bord de mer c'est franchement
irréel on pourrait être sur la costa del
sol le conflit quel conflit à tel aviv
ils en ont marre du penser à l'abri en
sécurité grâce au mur à 40 minutes à
peine en voiture de la cisjordanie
ils vivent dans une bulle la bulle de
tel aviv sur la plage rendez vous avec
samuel maoz
le réalisateur du film lebanon qui
raconte l'invasion israélienne au liban
en 82
vu de l'intérieur d'un chat
[Musique]
unigine alliot-marie cheminement
samuel maoz raconte sa propre histoire
appelé comme tous les jeunes hommes pour
trois ans de service militaire il s'est
retrouvé propulsé beau milieu d'une
guerre
obligé par ses supérieurs de tuer
[Applaudissements]
pour lui la parente insouciance de
tel-aviv n'est pas un problème
c'est peut-être même la solution on a
l'impression aujourd'hui ici à tel-aviv
en tout cas finalement la vie continue
normalement
comment c'est possible mais notre cause
sûr que nous sommes conscients de vivre
dans une bulle
il suffit de six heures de voiture pour
parcourir israël du nord au sud et 45
minutes
d'est en ouest donc nous savons ce qui
se passe autour de noël c'est pas si
loin mais c'est un processus salutaire
que d'arrêter de penser à la guerre et à
la sécurité pour essayer mener une vie
normale
c'est un processus psychologique ça qui
amènera la société a réalisé que la paix
est nécessaire si on veut avoir une vie
parfaitement normal je vais vous
raconter une anecdote il ya quelques
mois j'ai lu un article dans un journal
israélien le journaliste a révélé que
chaque citoyen doit payer 170 % de sa
facture d'électricité
parce qu'il doit aussi payer
l'électricité de gaza
le retentissement car cet article a été
beaucoup plus grand que n'importe quel
motif disons humanitaire tout d'un coup
les gens se sont mis à dire pourquoi
est-ce que je devrais payer
j'ai pas besoin de gaza donnons leur un
état palestinien
c'est pour ça que je pense que la
nouvelle génération nos enfants
amèneront la paix
non pas pour des raisons humanistes mais
plutôt pour des raisons égoïstes ou
capitaliste et pourquoi pas après tout
en fin de compte tout ce qui peut amener
la paix et légitime sauf tuer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]